[Musique]
dernier jour de compétition de cet open
de france 2019 ce dimanche 20 octobre
nicolas colsaerts eux disposent de trois
coups d'avancé avant d'aborder le
dernier tour le golfeur est le favori du
public
tiens franco belge s'est peut-être
nichols art
on verra on verra il a du mal mais tout
le monde a du mal aujourd'hui les
pronostics qui se sont avérées justes
nicolas colsaerts remporté au trou
numéro 18 cette édition 2010 9 son
premier titre depuis sept ans le golfeur
termine 12 coups sous le par avec un
coup d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
en conférence de presse le franco belge
de 36 ans vit ce moment avec sa famille
via son téléphone
c'est énormément de joueurs
voilà ça fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis
pro j'ai gagné deux fois j'aurais dû
gagner plus souvent comme je l ai déjà
dit souvent elle fait de gagner chez
vous c'est génial j'ai joué un peu
l'impression de faire partie du paysage
golfique français de leur côté les
français n'ont une fois de plus pas
réussi à dompter ce parcours de
l'albatros les chefs de file de la
délégation française victor perez et
benjamin hebert termine 16e c'est un
parcours que je connais bien qui me
résiste souvent a donc cette année je
suis content parce que j'ai quand même
réussi à faire une bonne semaine
il attend évidemment toujours encore
plus haut dans le leaderboard
mais indéniablement c'est une bonne
année pour le golf français sur
l'european tour avec victor perez qui a
la tête là du camp français actuellement
talonnée par benjamin hebert on n'oublie
pas également les jeunes pousses comme
romain langast ou encore michael
lorenzo-vera cette 103e édition de
l'open de france de golf s'achève ici
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
rendez vous l'année prochaine du 2 au 5
juillet à 2
[Musique]